mali has again postponed elections the
military says a democratic transition
won't take place for up to five years so
what happens now and can west african
regional leaders put the country back on
the path to civilian rule this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
deri nabogeda mali was supposed to hold
presidential and parliamentary elections
next month but the military-led
government has pushed that back by up to
five years army colonel assimi goyta who
staged two coups in less than a year
blames continuing insecurity in northern
mali major political parties have
condemned the delay and the regional
bloc ecowas is threatening to impose
more sanctions on military leaders if a
democratic transition doesn't happen
soon we'll bring in our guests in a
moment but first this report by victoria
gatenby
[Applause]
in downtown bamako malians are absorbing
the news the elections they were
promised next month aren't going to
happen and may not for up to five years
opposition leaders say the decision by
the transitional government is
unacceptable
er
holding meetings to say they want to be
in power for five years
i think this is
anti-constitutional anti-democratic and
it hasn't got any legitimacy
was sworn in last july following two
military coups in less than a year he
sought to unite malians and said
presidential elections would be held
but on thursday a conference charged
with recommending an election timetable
said the polls should be delayed by
between six months and five years
goethe's supporters agree now is not the
time for elections
post-electoral crises are more dangerous
than the situation we're in today
because we've seen genocides we've seen
bloodbaths across the world
today i think we need calm to reassure
the population here and elsewhere
the international community must
understand that the lesser evil today is
addressing the concerns of malians
despite criticism of the interim
government analysts say it has managed
to bring some stability to mali the
government in bamako is is
to a large extent a step ahead of every
everyone you just have to look at how
they've been able to change the reality
on the ground in a very incremental but
very steady
basis the west african regional block
ecowas is expected to discuss the
situation next week it's already imposed
sanctions on officials and has promised
more if mali's leaders don't produce a
plan for a democratic transition
victoria gatenby
al-jazeera so how did we get here well
back in 2012 tuareg's separatists took
over large parts of northern mali
al-qaeda and isil-linked fighters also
entered the region
in january 2013 former colonial power
france sent in troops to remove the
armed groups but after struggling for
nine years france announced that it
would end its operation early in 2022
protests against former president
ibrahim bupa karkata began in june 2020
many accused him of failing to fix
insecurity corruption and the economy
so military leaders took power two
months later forcing keita to resign
after seven years in office
the international community condemned
the coup
the junta leader asimi goyta had agreed
to return power to civilians elections
were supposed to be held after an
18-month transitional period
[Music]
let's bring in our guests joining us
from bamako is ornela modern head of the
sahel program at the institute for
security studies in accra emmanuel
kawesian-ing director of research at the
kofi annan international peacekeeping
training center and joining us from
copenhagen is cena caldera evan kilday
who's the senior researcher on security
and development in the sahel region at
the danish institute for international
studies welcome to the program uh thanks
so much for joining us or nella
i'll begin with you you say that you're
not surprised by this postponement but
what is surprising to you is the
boldness of proposing an up to five year
delay what does that signal to you
well as you said um the
suggestion to postpone the timelines i
think uh
should
should not come as a surprise for for
most stakeholders we used to have um
electoral timelines that were quite
unrealistic in the first place and uh by
which the current uh transitional
government as opposed to the previous
one never formally uh adhered to so um
that
that
a postponement postponement would be uh
suggested is not that surprising what is
indeed is
the notion that this would go into five
years now it's it should be noted that
um
you know
officials in bamako as well as the
foreign minister himself had clarified
uh uh including to to the malian uh
national television that in fact these
five years should be seen as a maximum
time timeline so one question i think is
to what extent is are these five five
years really uh what the government is
aiming for or
as opposed to to what extent is it a
posture for for negotiations okay so how
is this being viewed in mali itself
well um
the opinions are are very mixed so
an important element i think is that uh
this suggestion does not come from
nowhere right so the marine government
organized what really wasn't a
conference as as was mentioned in your
reports but a process a consultation
process national consultation process
which involved thousands of people
across the country
and ended up with this suggestion so
what this process does is that it it
lands the proposition of extension some
level of
apparent
popular legitimacy
this of course makes it much harder for
external actions like acos and and
others to to simply discard it um
in the current context okay important
point yeah apologies let me just bring
in our other guests uh that's an
important point that you raise uh
kwesianing um so
as as um ornella was just saying this
this decision was backed by a national
consultation process so do you think
that it's going to make it difficult for
bodies like echoes for or others to
question it
well
no i think
echoes lost the plot right from the word
go
for several reasons
right when the coup took place echoes
misconstrued and misunderstood
the shifting
forces i mean power correlations that's
number one
number two echoes misunderstood the
changing
geopolitics of mali itself
and then the subreddit and the role of
other external actors that the new
leaders
you know
could go to for support
you know so the
set of the range of tools in ecoass's
toolbox
actually is becoming limited by the day
uh so for me as oneella has said this is
this has not come as a surprise
and i think for echoers to presuppose
that people who are tested power would
basically just go back to the barracks
and hold an election
when those who are pushing for change
themselves
have very disturbing skeletons in their
cupboard okay so crazy so when echo has
threatened sanctions which it has uh for
for the postponement of these elections
first of all will it follow through and
second of all will sanctions make a
difference
sanctions will make a difference
at all because the range of sanctions
that are available
will not be effective what you are going
to prevent the head of state and his
people from getting medical help
freezing their bank accounts preventing
them from traveling preventing their
kids from going to school wherever they
go to
these are minimal superficial
interventions that do not touch the
crust of the problem
the problem is that the old political
elites have lost
ground they've been corrupt abusive
disrespectful
and these new leaders are using a
language that appeals to the people and
as o'neill has said
the decision for the five years is only
a bargaining ship and opening for
negotiations in which they will
eventually come to say two and a half
years to three years
but getting to that yes point
depends on the quality of the
negotiations that equals
the table okay and i think right from
when this series of coup started i think
request has not managed to show that
leadership that we are looking for okay
let's bring in copenhagen and cine over
to you what is your take and how do you
see this postponement
i agree with my colleague that this
might not be
very surprising and it also seems as is
what the junta has actually achieved
here is uh constructing quite a lot of a
grey zone of a constitutional order that
allows them to
operate quite freely because the
international
coalition led by the european forces is
definitely in a dilemma here because
they're so deeply engaged and the logic
behind the european contingent is also
that
um the european security depends on the
security in these african states and
that means that it's very difficult at
this point in time to actually
make any solid um sanctions against this
so uh
that way they have sort of uh the the
units have sort of gained the strategic
up at hand as far as i see it what i
think is a bit surprising is to what
extent have there been other actors
which crazy also
announced that have made some sort of
guarantee to security or guarantee for
backing the yonza if they decide to go
ahead with this
plan which we also see now has been
contested by several political parties
when you say other actors who are you
referring to here
particularly the rumors around
the wagner group's engagement but of
course also russia's um
engagement and russia is of course not a
illegitimate partner but the problem for
europe is that europe has
quite a lot of different points of
interest
in
in other regions as well
so
europe and france also does not
necessarily approve of a russian
influence in
in the region and what's problematic in
in that uptick is that
these external actors end up being
engaged for other reasons than creating
peace and stability but they are more
there to protect their own geopolitical
strategic interests and that
to me seems quite dangerous and what
we're also seeing is that
from the united there's a lot of
populist
speak and there's also a lot of this
from this information campaign but um
all that this information campaigns
about french interest is not only
produced by russia itself we must not uh
forget how much actually popular
discontent there is with um okay we're
going to talk about the french
involvement as well as the russian
involvement in just a moment but first
um or nella uh one question to you
because the the the military
uh is blaming continuing insecurity in
northern mali as
one of the reasons for for this
postponement does
the security situation in parts of the
country actually allow for the
government to hold elections at this
point
so
the the simple answer would be no
but
um no uh the
the
the security situation right now is is
extremely difficult on the ground uh
state representatives are estimated to
be actually present on the field in
about a third of the country only so it
would be really difficult to hold
elections that said this is not the only
reason and perhaps not even the main
reason why this postponement
postponement is happening um another
important element is the uptight for
change that um that money expressed in
which this government is essentially
promising to
uh to
to provide if given more time the memory
of the 2015 election after the pre uh
in in 2012 is still quite vivid um among
public opinion here and there is a
feeling that back then um there was a
sort of unfulfilled
promise that mali uh let echo west and
others brush it into elections that
essentially didn't change anything
didn't solve anything and that now seven
years later we're still in this
situation so this appetite or this um
this this eagerness for uh for change is
also what the the the transitional
government is is promising so that i
think is important to to mention along
with this notion of having a five five
years extension they have
proposed um a more specific timeline for
the various reforms which are
fundamental reforms that malians are are
asking for and which previous uh elected
uh elites as well as their international
partners failed to
uh to
to deliver impact okay uh questioning
which um
or who i mean cenia was touching upon
this a moment ago but what country would
have been given uh its blessing for the
for the postponement surely this is not
a decision that the military can come to
decide on themselves is it
i mean the military
guys are smart
they've looked at the
geopolitical situation
they've seen the changes
and they've decided to play their cats
and play very deftly now the two top men
have studied
in
russia they have their links we are
seeing a resurgence for russia with an
aggressive foreign and defense and
economic policy all around the
sub-region we are seeing the wagner
group
you know in central africa republic and
elsewhere and here realize the crust of
the malian discomfort
the sheer hypocrisy
of those who are saying but what is the
working group here
almost every western european country
talking
about the role of the russians have had
their own mercenaries crisscrossing the
subregion before now the russians do say
the russians however do say that russian
trainers are in the country as part of a
bilateral agreement between mali and
russia that's what they say and there
are other bilateral agreements in which
their trainers are in mali so
so so what's russia doing is it has it
stepped in to fill the security gap when
france announced that it would be
withdrawing its troops
no i mean russia has always been around
i mean let's not forget that
russia has has grown out of the old
soviet union and the soviet union has
been a major player just like china on
this continent since the 1950s okay so
these are
old relationships that are being giving
new clothing
now by the number of analysts from
elsewhere tend to forget and to
misconstrue
the
character
and the analysis emanating from bamako
but this is not only a barbarical the
significance about bamako
is that where the international
community to fail
how will gilly see this
what leverage can we have with guinea
and will this
cascade into other countries where
similar difficulties as oneella was
talking about within the political
economic and social elites
are creating the basis
for instability
so getting mali right is very important
unfortunately
i think the way most people are looking
at it is wrong russia is not a problem
the wagner group is not the problem
certainly we need to look at a broader
stakeholder group
in which
people who have been marginalized women
youth right and failed victims right
have their voices brought to the table
okay uh cine would you would you like to
add on to uh what uh we were hearing
from uh questioning
i i definitely think it's a very
important point raised by crazy this
thing that even
10 years ago no one had imagined
this kind of jihadist insurgency in the
sahel and we've seen the
the speed and the escalation
through which violence which is not only
by committed by jihadist groups but also
by all kinds of
self-defense militias that in the vacuum
of
security provision by
government forces is able to thrive on
violence and also we see how security
forces are also producing violence in
itself so it's extremely important that
that this
construction of this as only being a
jihadist threat it also points to so
many uh deep lying
problems of security provision for
ordinary citizens in the region which is
not only limited to mali but of course
the kind of impunity that is seen and
the kind of
diplomatic deadlock
that is
observed in mali is extremely worrying
because i think what we need to
understand is also that these foreign
interventions are not occupying forces
they are inter interventions by
invitation and that means that they rely
on this host nation
to um cooperate and to invite them into
the territory but that also gives a lot
of leverage to these kinds of of
governments however male constructed and
malfunctioning they may be so it what we
are saying in in the academic
is that these in um
uh
partner states or the states in the
sahel they are able to tame
interventions that means that they are
completely able to use all these foreign
investments right uh for pursuing their
own interests and and i think that's
that's something we need to take into
consideration when there is this idea
that we can kind of construct security
in a region like the sahel we forget uh
actors on the ground with political okay
let me bring in our economic interest
let me bring in arnella because
in germany what we're hearing now is the
the parliamentary commissioner for the
armed forces said that the german army
should evaluate its role in mali and
consider ending military operations
there as we've been talking the french
military is in the process of winding
down its operations in the country as
well are these moves welcomed by malians
the posture that international actors
are taking generally um
uh is
is
appreciated in in very different ways by
malians of course there has been some uh
concern about the the drawdown of bakken
um
but again i mean
this is not what the the
the postponements of the uh electoral
timelines
we're just looking at it now in the
context of the security situation in the
country of course yeah
of course i i would like to get back to
one thing you you said
earlier which you know was this question
of well um whether or not uh malian
authorities could have just taken this
decision on their own i believe this is
one of the mistakes that the
international community has been making
from the get-go to
to minimize
the agency of
of national authorities because because
they emanate from approach
perhaps also for
other reasons one of the things we have
seen through
repeatedly i think is the ability of
this government to to to shift the
tables to to to shift uh power that
power dynamics and essentially
uh creates leeway for
for uh negotiations for themselves and
and essentially at the end of the day
get what they want so this kind of
minimizing and
treat
your implant that they should be treated
as
uh
junior diplomats i think is a strategic
mistake which i i would not encourage uh
perpetuating oh crazy would uh
would you like to respond to uh to what
we heard from ernella and also we just
have a few minutes left what do you
think is going to happen next how is
this going to play out
well i think i agree with o'neil
o'neil this consistent strategic
miscalculations by outsiders that the
regime in bamako doesn't have agency is
false what we are going to see in the
next couple of months
is an echo as that would seek to regain
the initiative but it has very limited
tools to play with
you know so i am
guessing
uh that we are going to look at a
compromise solution that looks at so
anywhere between two and half years to
three years for the transition process
now within that period the regime and
the course will have to get
the extremist violence under control
which i know is almost impossible
because that violence is spreading but
mali
it's a touchy point
and the way that equates and the wider
international community with the malians
resolve this problem will be indicative
of how stable the sun region is in 2022
and afterwards okay uh cine last words
for you in 30 seconds what do you think
is going to happen next how is this
going to play out
i also see this continued diplomatic um
game
in between these different actors i also
see that perhaps the five years was an
optimistic sort of bit and perhaps a
negotiated settlement within the time
range of two to three years is it could
be what we're heading at and probably
that the european
missions and interventions will
be have to accept that because i also
see that we are not withdrawing from the
sahel i think what it's important to
raise that the french is reorganizing
its troops so it's more of a training
and assist
mission and but also at a distance so
we're going to see more drone more kind
of
high technological engagement but not
necessarily less investment in the
region okay we'll have to leave it there
on that and thank you so much uh for
joining us ornella motoran emmanuel
cuisine and cna cold rev kilday thanks
so much for your time thank you for
watching you can see the program again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com
for further discussion you can go to our
facebook page it's facebook.com forward
slash aj inside story you can join the
conversation on twitter our handle is aj
inside story from myself and the whole
team right here in delhi thanks for
watching
and bye bye for now
[Music]